Hey Collider fans, I'm John Rocha.
"The Meg" swims and chomps its way into
theaters this weekend and we thought
we'd count down the Top 5 Shark Movie Deaths.
Now there have been many
memorable shark attacks on film
#Batman1966 #SharkRepellent
but we wanted to look at some
of the best deaths. A warning to all of
you: if you're squeamish then make sure
you've got a trash can nearby to drop
your Chum into
[Vomiting]
We start off our list with one of the
most horrific shark deaths on film, yet
one where we never even see a shark
Steven Spielberg's "Jaws" has scared
generations of film-goers for years.
One of the many reasons why is the opening
scene of the movie: a young woman has
swum out into the ocean at night after
enjoying a beach campfire. The water is
peaceful and the buoy dings in the
distance. We got a peaceful easy feeling,
but it doesn't last long - the young woman
is suddenly taken underwater three times
and begins to freak out, realizing the
terror she is in. The shark drags her
back and forth in the water. We hear
these horrible sounds of absolute terror
bursting out of her mouth.
The attack lasts 45 seconds and
Spielberg (that crafty mofo) even teases
us that the young woman might escape
when she is dragged to the buoy and the
shark attack stops. The respit only
lasts a couple of seconds before the
shark returns and takes her underwater
to her death, the water is calm again and
we are left with a terror that will
carry us through the rest of the movie.
Our #4 Movie Shark Death comes
from "Open Water" in the film a couple on
vacation Susan and Daniel gets stranded
when a tourist boat accident that leaves
them behind and they spend the movie
fighting off a shark in you guessed it
open water (boom, nailed it!) Susan's death
is a scary unsettling yet surprisingly
empowering one after daniel is attacked
earlier and eaten overnight Susan spots
Daniels remains floating in the water
the next morning she has almost no time
to grieve her loss however because she
also spies with her little eye something
that begins with an S and that's SHARKS.
More have shown up to join Daniel's
attacker and are thrashing about
whipping themselves into a feeding
frenzy
realizing she is about to become a KFC
meal Susan makes the surprising decision
to take her air tanks and swimming
goggles off let them float away and
defiantly chooses to drown herself.
Yeah there's no blood or ripping off
body parts but it's a powerful shark movie
death nonetheless. I mean what would you do?
#3 in our list is
a 2-for-1 deal from "The Shallows"
directed by Jaume Collet-Sera. In the
film Blake Lively plays Nancy a young
woman who's coming to terms with the
death of her mother and visits a remote
beach in Mexico after a long day of
surfing with two locals one with a GoPro
on his head
Nancy decides to wade out into the water
one more time and notices a humpback
whale carcass as she swims towards it a
shark suddenly attacks her biting her
leg and shattering her surfboard she
eventually swims to safety on a rock
formation patches up her leg and spends
the night there the next morning the two
local surfers return and begin to wade
out to her
Nancy yells them to go back but they do
not listen suddenly one of the surface
is attacked by a shark and eaten amidst
his screams the other local server
he swims towards Nancy he eventually
disappears under the water and we think
the shark has claimed him but he pops up
moments later screaming in Spanish for
Nancy to help him get onto the rocks we
see the terror in Nancy's face through
the surfers GoPro as she desperately
tries to save him
the shark ferociously takes him
underwater and Nancy is left with a nice
pool of blood bubbling up to the surface
Nancy you in danger girl.
#2 our list of the top 5 shark movie
deaths is Samuel L. Jackson in "Deep Blue Sea"
Yeah you know this was coming. The
film, directed by Renny Harlin, is set in
an isolated underwater facility where a
team of scientists is researching how
they can genetically engineer sharks to
help fight Alzheimer's say what
yeah it's Renny Harlin let's just move
on Jackson plays Russell Franklin a
corporate executive who's been sent to
the facility to figure out what's gone
wrong with these experiments the Sharks
are worn out super-intelligent
eventually break out and terrorize the
scientists and Sam Jackson Sam steps
forward to try to rally the troops to
deliver what could have been the
greatest film monologue ever!
Unfortunately he never finishes it as
one of the motherfucking sharks suddenly
jumps out of the water,
grabs Jackson in its jaws, and drags him
to his death. It's one of the most
shocking shark movie deaths ever and may
be the last time anything man or creature
ever got the best of Sam Jackson on film.
And finally our #1
shark movie death is the
death of Robert Shaw's Quint in "Jaws"
Quint is one of the last remaining
survivors of the USS Indianapolis a ship
that was torpedoed by a Japanese sub in
World War two 1,100 men went into the
water were attacked by sharks and only
316 men survived going to spend the rest
of his life hunting sharks as a revenge
he chief Brody and Hooper are chasing a
25-foot shark that was terrorizing Amity
after thinking they might finally be
getting the better of the shark in
attacks Hooper shark kage and then
quickly launches itself almost
full-bodied onto quints slowly sinking
boat this causes the boat to become a
ramp essentially and Quint starts to
slide down it he desperately tries to
hold on to a shelf but an air tank of
Hooper's rolls over his hand forcing him
to let go he tries to grab on a Brody's
hand but slips through and slides down
to the shark he furiously kicks at the
Shark's snout
trying to avoid its mouth but to no
avail the shark sinks its teeth into
Quinn's body and squeezes the life and
blood out of him amidst his squeals and
futile knife stabs he has slowly dragged
into the water to join us fallen
comrades from the USS Indianapolis.
Well there you have it our top 5 shark movie
deaths - hope you like them! Remember to
catch "The Meg" in theaters this weekend
let us know what your top 5 shark movie
deaths would be in the comments
below. Remember to like and share this
video on your social media and subscribe
to Collider for more fun videos just
like this one
[More Vomiting]
[Music]